[Music]
[Applause]
that performance of carmen in london
happened before the pandemic and of
course opera has been largely silenced
like most of the performing arts
but the english national opera is using
its downtime to fight covet 19.
liz palmer met a vocal coach helping
breathe new hope
into patients with long-term side
effects from the virus
for sheba not so long ago a simple
stroll in the sun
was unimaginable i couldn't even
go from my bed to the kitchen without
having to sit down and catch my breath
sheba beat kovid this winter but never
got her breath back
i felt that i needed more air in my
lungs i felt as if i was drowning at
times
covid patients even those who don't end
up on ventilators can be left with
so-called long coved
chronically short of breath
enter the english national opera with a
prescription
so some really simple things that we do
are around
physicalizing airflow so if you think if
you breathe in
and breathe out operatic singing coach
susie zumpa is helping long covered
patients breathe again
and it starts with posture because it's
really difficult to breathe well
if you're physically collapsed and
people who've been ill are often a bit
crunched
and just place it on your neck very
gently susie
uncrunches them in an online zoom course
that uses musical exercises to teach
relaxation and breath control
sheba was one of the very first to sign
up and i'm so glad i did
because it's pulled me out of darkness
it was literally a breath of fresh air
for me you can think of it as
physiotherapy for the lungs
[Music]
[Music]
amazing i'm loving the eyebrow accent
that goes with it
[Applause]
here's the english national opera on
stage pre pandemic
the exercises that gave the singers
their power were adapted by doctors
for long covert patients it's an
unlikely fit
opera and covert it's an odd predicament
actually that at a time where
we're unable to sing the very craft of
singing is something that has been
useful and beneficial and had and had
value to people at this time
[Music]
online the class learns lullabies
susie may be the only one unmuted but
everybody benefits and i have to ask how
are you now
are you better i'm much better and i
don't think it would have been possible
if i didn't have this
fantastic tool to guide me through this
dark time
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in london
this palmer's now an opera singer i love
it i wouldn't have put the two together
but i could see
it makes sense when you see it right it
does make sense how it worked for
rehabilitation of course if i were
singing opera people would need a
different kind of rehabilitation
me too